welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and this video we're turning it up to 11
to break down the brand new trailer for
stranger things season 4.
throughout this video we're going to be
pointing out some of the easter eggs and
giving our theories on what the plot is
and where things will be going in the
show
full spoilers ahead so if you aren't
caught up with the series then i highly
recommend that you go through the
doorway now
make sure you like the video if you
enjoy it and don't forget to subscribe
for more stranger things as we get them
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so according to finn wolfhard
season 4 of stranger things is going to
be the most horrifying hell ride through
hawkins
that we've ever had last season ended
with the group taking part in the battle
of the star court
in which jim hopper was assumed to have
died however the post-credits scene
teased at an american being held captive
and the trailer showed us that jim was
still alive and well in russia
like 11 he was very much at the behest
of a government
and had his head shaved much like her
the duffer brothers cleared it up and
said that this was actually kamchatka
and that hopper would be facing enemies
both human and worse
now at this location we also know there
is a demogorgon
so it's going to be interesting to see
if any more of the monsters pop up
the russians were using forced labor to
help build the railroad tracks
and it looks like a prisoner camp due to
the guards patrolling it and shouting at
the people there
a train line being built is very
interesting as of course it could be a
way to transport creatures that come
from the upside down
now as for the show in general i think
we have to acknowledge further comments
made by the duffer brothers when they
discussed the season they stated that
something long buried and forgotten
would be emerging once more and it looks
like you better hold on to your butts
because the mind flayer is back the
russians are clearly still carrying out
experiments on the upside down
and they may create a way for the
creatures to come across into our world
we know that the first episode of season
four will be called the hellfire club
which is likely a nod to the x-men the
club tried to recruit gene grey
who of course has telekinetic powers
just like 11.
now this takes us into the first look
which has a lot of fans
including me slightly confused i have
seen a couple of complaints stating that
they're just telling a story we already
know
which is the origin of 11. whilst i do
think that is the case and that this
is a prequel thing rather than 11 being
captured and then put back in for
testing
i think it does tease out what season 4
will be centered around
i went fully in depth on this maybe too
far and i just want to give a reach
warning but hopefully after i
explain it you'll agree with me or else
they'll be troubled now i believe that
this teaser trailer is hinting at
several of the other children from this
lab
coming back into the show i think they
will be introduced as new characters
and potentially this could be the
aforementioned hellfire club
if we're sticking with the x-men
metaphor then maybe all these children
have incredible abilities and powers
now in the show we already have come
across one of these kids
namely kali aka eight we discovered that
she escaped
the lab years and years before and this
is why there was a lot of mystery
surrounding her
but with 11 being free too and the
doctors involved in it being nowhere to
be seen
it does make sense that the other
children managed to get out as well
in this trailer there are several hints
towards this and a heavy focus
on the kits themselves however it goes
way beyond that
and throughout the teaser there are
several numbers that appear
the first one is on the clock in which
we see that the time is 3.
this could either be pointing towards
the number 12 3
or perhaps even both next we cut to the
camera
and if you turn the brightness upon it
you can see that there is a 5 in the
reflection
we also see a magic 8 ball and though we
don't get the number
shown directly to us we do get the
triangle saying
signs point to yes it's long been
theorized that cali would return
and it's even been hinted at by the
writers therefore the signs point to it
being yes
that she's back see i told you there was
going to be a lot of reaching
now next we see a disc i want to say
disc it might not be
but we see a disc being dropped through
some nails the disc
lands in seven potentially hinting at
this character too
at this point there are more numbers
revealed including three five and six
however i'm unsure exactly on whether
this confirms them or not
the clock hit three as we started the
trailer the eight ball was shook to
hammer home we could be getting eight
and the disc hitting seven i think means
that they're in it too
however i might be wrong from all out
reaching and the numbers that we see
could just not be the people involved at
all perhaps i should have stretched
before i reached this horde
i'll tell you what though i believe that
the children we see in the next shot
are the ones who could be popping up as
teens and we may be introduced to them
properly
now the trailer is creepy as hell and
this is obviously meant to be a nursery
or classroom
and we see the kids playing games and so
on but the sterile environment
is just so off-putting the clock
constantly ticking away in the
background
makes it seem like the whole fun
environment that this is supposed to be
has been completely subverted and you
definitely wouldn't want to send your
kids here
there's a shot where they weirdly crawl
in the lines of a rainbow
which just doesn't feel natural and it's
all very
unnerving next we see the back of dr
martin brenner's head
brenner apparently died after being
killed by a demogorgon
but i just have a suspicion that he's
still alive now whilst
i do think that this is a prequel moment
we never saw his body
and i would love to see him pop up in
flashbacks before it's revealed that
he's actually still alive
who knows he may even end up helping 11
get to hopper
i think he will be a big character in
the show once more
the duffer brothers could be referring
to brenna when they talk about something
long forgotten
as at this point he feels like a distant
memory he enters where the children are
and says good morning children
to which they respond with good morning
papa a nickname that he had in the show
we then go past even more numbers which
contain
7 9 10 and lastly 11 who we settle on
now the numbers theory might be
completely wrong i just feel like it's
constantly hitting us over the head with
them and in this trailer we are in an
environment
where children were given numbers as
names this makes me think the entire
teaser is put in place
just to let us know that the kids will
be in the show all grown up
and helping 11 to get her powers back
she did of course lose them
at the end of the last season and i do
believe that her trying to regain these
in order to find hopper
will be a big plot point brenner says i
have something very special planned for
you
and we then hear a voice say 11 are you
listening
at this point millie bobby brown's eyes
are shown waking up
this seems to be her as she currently is
rather than how she was in the first
season
and this may even be a therapy session
or a hypnosis one
i could actually see this scene being
her revisiting these moments from her
memories
in order to recall certain points in her
past i think that probably
is very likely as the scene as a whole
is very nightmarish
and it's definitely something that you
wouldn't really want to remember now
that is a new look
but the description on the video
interestingly contains numbers too
these could be a release date it could
be setting something else up
but let me know below if you have a
theory now as for the trailer
you know i was confused at first but in
the end they've done a really good job
of getting me back on board the hype
train
initially yeah i had no idea what was
going on but after switching on that
heavy spoilers brain and deep diving
there are a couple of cool tidbits the
pandemic caused a lot of issues with the
show
but now that things are slowly slowly
slowly opening up
we're able to pick up where we left off
this season actually started shooting
all the way back in october 29
so it has been a while but i'm glad that
we're finally here
at the moment i'm unsure whether this
will be the last season or not
and the creative team have gone back and
forth between wanting to do two more
seasons of the show
or just the one they have however said
that there's a big death coming
and it will be interesting to see what
happens i know a lot of you think that
it's going to be 11 who dies
but after all she's been through i do
think she deserves a happy ending
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the teaser so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as to thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the trailer
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
we've got two great videos on screen
right now
that you're definitely gonna love i
promise you that maybe not but
just check them out anyway if you if
you're still here i know you haven't
left
and thanks for sitting through the video
until the end i've been paul you've been
the best
take care and that's another terrible
outro goodbye you